[SPEAKER_01]: I could have well done at around 10 p.m. You guys discussed things.
[SPEAKER_00]: So you got a problem with me saying I could levitate?
[SPEAKER_01]: No, it's just really funny.
[SPEAKER_01]: Because you looked at me and I'm like, and I could levitate.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, I mean, it's, you know, sometimes it's a little awkward.
[SPEAKER_00]: Hey, I don't usually, I usually don't just lead with like what spells I can do, but we were talking about, he was saying that it would, he thought it would be hard or impossible.
[SPEAKER_00]: No, he's all, you're a magical user, I was like, yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: And like, let's take it.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, you didn't see the explosions on the dock, the wall of fire?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: He didn't, by the way, because he's in the garrison.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, I mean, now, are you ready for this?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, I'm ready.
[SPEAKER_01]: You still want me to make the masks?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: I do think that if you can make...
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, at least one.
[SPEAKER_00]: If you can pull off a good one, great.
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, that's awesome.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's absolutely necessary if you have to put all your time because you've only got two or three good ones.
[SPEAKER_00]: If you can do three that are passable, that would be amazing also.
[SPEAKER_00]: So, I mean, I'd like you to definitely see that.
[SPEAKER_00]: Get some, like, gooey eyes.
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, you saw roughly what their faces were, so I don't know what you need to start with, but I'm sure that the captain... Or you could just grab a dead hobgoblin and just let me look at it.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, they'll be bringing them in imminently here.
[SPEAKER_00]: And we'll see how many salvageable suits there are of armor.
[SPEAKER_00]: I can't cast magic and wear one of those things, but, I mean, I can put a cloak on if they had a cloak.
[SPEAKER_01]: You can't put a paper mache head on?
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, I guess I could put a paper mache hat on, but I'm gonna be levitating, remember?
[SPEAKER_00]: You guys will be up there directly.
[SPEAKER_00]: I will be levitating.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's right.
[SPEAKER_01]: You'll be levitating.
[SPEAKER_01]: My bad.
[SPEAKER_01]: Geez.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm not- What little spell is that?
[SPEAKER_00]: If I need to walk around with a hobgoblin paper mache on mask, things have really gotten fucked up.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm gonna be behind.
[SPEAKER_01]: I can just imagine a hobgoblin with a bad paper mache.
[SPEAKER_01]: Let me tell you what the... Well...
[SPEAKER_00]: The other hobgoblins are like, what the fuck?
[SPEAKER_00]: Now, I need, I need, I need you to know you're probably gonna need to be able to take orders from, not from me, from Gouge.
[SPEAKER_00]: Why are you, like, what?
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm telling you you're gonna need... Is Gouge just a nut job?
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, yeah, that's beside the point.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's also a really deadly nut job.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm telling you that if you're going to go on this, you can stay with the captain if you want, and you can do great service.
[SPEAKER_00]: No, he'll go with you.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so then you're going to...
[SPEAKER_00]: I guarantee you... How do you know this guy?
[SPEAKER_00]: I've fought a war with him on the eastern... Eastern... Eastern war.
[SPEAKER_00]: I fought a war with him.
[SPEAKER_00]: What war?
[SPEAKER_00]: The Great Kingdom, was it a Great Kingdom or was it... South Province.
[SPEAKER_00]: South Province.
[SPEAKER_00]: Not Great.
[SPEAKER_01]: And a D. The land of a D. But the South Province is allied with the Great Kingdom.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: The South Province of the Great Kingdom.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, that's what it is.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, you were asking me about Gouch.
[SPEAKER_00]: I've traveled prior to the war fighting with him on the infrastructure.
[SPEAKER_01]: I've also... Is he like an ADHD million miles a minute nut job that has a...
[SPEAKER_00]: He's a killer.
[SPEAKER_01]: Slit throat hand?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, he's a killer.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, cool.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's nice.
[SPEAKER_00]: So I'm just saying, like, he'll know who you are.
[SPEAKER_00]: So what if I disagree with him?
[SPEAKER_00]: He'll know who you are.
[SPEAKER_00]: Like, they were concerned, he was concerned about your welfare, so he already knows who you are.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm just saying that, like, on this kind of a mission, if he's gonna, you can still have agency, you can still, obviously, you have skills.
[SPEAKER_00]: So I'm not saying you have to keep your mouth shut and, like, bend over.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm just saying you need to, like,
[SPEAKER_00]: You just need to be ready.
[SPEAKER_00]: If he tells you that he's gonna need you to do something, arguing's not in his wheelhouse.
[SPEAKER_00]: Anytime that I've ever argued with Gouge, I've been half prepared to have to kill him or try to kill him.
[SPEAKER_00]: In case the arguing wins.
[SPEAKER_00]: But no, we just never argued.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm just saying, that's how I approach.
[SPEAKER_00]: You just said you've argued every time you've argued with me.
[SPEAKER_00]: No, every time I've ever thought that there was an argument coming.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh.
[SPEAKER_00]: Which, trust me, there were many.
[SPEAKER_00]: So, I'll bark nobody?
[SPEAKER_00]: Me?
[SPEAKER_00]: I levitate shit.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm busy levitating.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's you.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, and I do walls of fire.
[SPEAKER_00]: Walls of fire.
[SPEAKER_00]: I blow towers with troops in them up.
[SPEAKER_01]: Blowing towers with troops in them and levitating them.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right.
[SPEAKER_01]: I also have the magic missiles.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's great.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, your magic missiles.
[SPEAKER_00]: I got more.
[SPEAKER_01]: You got more.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm sure you do.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm sure you'll be levitating all of you.
[SPEAKER_01]: Look, are you going to be fine with this?
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm sure you'll levitate your ass right up to the tower.
[SPEAKER_00]: Are you going to be fine with gouge running the mission?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, as long as he's not wagging his dick in my face.
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't think he will.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, then we'll be good.
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, I don't, I mean, unless he's changed a lot.
[SPEAKER_00]: Depends on how much he says to drink.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, that's not right.
[SPEAKER_00]: He's never done that to me.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, we'll be good.
[SPEAKER_00]: He has seen me get beat up by an undead revenant while he sipped his wine.
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't think he actually ever raised his hand, did he?
[SPEAKER_00]: No.
[SPEAKER_01]: It was karma, I guess, because we're laughing as he was all like... You gotta just sit there and go, whoa, that's funny.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, so paper mache.
[SPEAKER_00]: Disguise.
[SPEAKER_01]: Alright.
[SPEAKER_00]: Is there anything I can do to help?
[SPEAKER_00]: You can levitate.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'll go levitate him.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you wish to start a long rest?
[SPEAKER_01]: If you do that, that will...
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, well, if I've had a short rest... Can I join another short rest?
[SPEAKER_00]: Does that equal a long rest?
[SPEAKER_00]: No.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so it would have to be... Is a long rest for me four hours?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: So if you start now, it'll be 2am.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, so I'm gonna go meditate, but I don't know if I'll be able to finish it.
[SPEAKER_00]: But I already did get a short rest, so I got half of my spells that I had cast by.
[SPEAKER_00]: You can get three spell slots back.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, that's right, that's right.
[SPEAKER_00]: And let me see if I already...
[SPEAKER_00]: So I didn't erase anything.
[SPEAKER_00]: So I only cast Wall of Fire once.
[SPEAKER_00]: I cast Fireball once.
[SPEAKER_00]: I didn't cast anything else.
[SPEAKER_00]: So that would either be getting my Fireball back or my... Oh, I couldn't actually get that.
[SPEAKER_00]: It would be your Fireball.
[SPEAKER_00]: So it would be my Fireball back.
[SPEAKER_00]: Or at least the one third level slot.
[SPEAKER_00]: And if he wanted to push it till later...
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, I mean, I'll go ahead and start meditating.
[SPEAKER_00]: Worst case scenario, you're gonna do your disguise.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'll go meditate.
[SPEAKER_00]: The captain knows what the plan is.
[SPEAKER_00]: So you can talk to Gouge.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm gonna go meditate.
[SPEAKER_00]: Not meditate.
[SPEAKER_00]: You're gonna make that big deal every time.
[SPEAKER_00]: You're gonna be talking to Gouge, because I can't like have you disturb my meditation and still be able to recover.
[SPEAKER_01]: Alright, cool, whatever.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'll just make it paper mache.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, this is the plan.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Basically, you want to tell Gouge that you can attack
[SPEAKER_01]: Or try and infiltrate the helm from the back side.
[SPEAKER_01]: Climb upon the walls over here and try and enter it that way.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's the plan that you guys have come up with?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: While the troops demonstrate to draw attention to the front.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right.
[SPEAKER_01]: Other things you may want to remember is that there are underground water caves, even though you don't know where the entrance to those are.
[SPEAKER_01]: You should tell him that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I will.
[SPEAKER_01]: God, don't worry.
[SPEAKER_01]: You just go meditate and levitate, alright?
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm gonna be making these.
[SPEAKER_01]: Goblin... God, this is the wackiest thing ever.
[SPEAKER_01]: The levitating or the meditating?
[SPEAKER_01]: No, not the levitating.
[SPEAKER_01]: I've seen plenty of people levitating.
[SPEAKER_01]: The hobgoblins.
[SPEAKER_01]: The hobgoblin paper-shamed masks.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, you're the one that said paper-shamed.
[SPEAKER_00]: I suggested you skin one of their faces.
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't want to skin one of their faces, Dad.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's a nasty job.
[SPEAKER_01]: Basically, what you're doing...
[SPEAKER_01]: If you want to do that for your own mask, go ahead.
[SPEAKER_01]: If you're making a disguise, if you want to try and make a disguise.
[SPEAKER_01]: I've never skinned nobody, and I'm like...
[SPEAKER_00]: You're just not willing to do what's necessary.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, would you like to levitate over here and do it?
[SPEAKER_00]: Show me.
[SPEAKER_00]: No, I gotta meditate so I can give my back a spell back.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, go meditate.
[SPEAKER_00]: Levitate.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I can meditate.
[SPEAKER_00]: Shut up.
[SPEAKER_00]: You looked at me too.
[SPEAKER_01]: You like turned and looked.
[SPEAKER_01]: I was like...
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, like I said, I'm not used to telling people what spells I can do.
[SPEAKER_01]: I was like, should I be saying I can levitate?
[SPEAKER_01]: And then you're all, and I can levitate.
[SPEAKER_00]: Obviously, I shouldn't have said shit so that you weren't going to be giggling every, like, 30 minutes.
[SPEAKER_00]: I can see you on Friday, you're going to be all like, ooh, he can levitate.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, I'll be like, well, you can levitate.
[SPEAKER_00]: Actually, I need to look to see how high I can levitate.
[SPEAKER_00]: That would suck them all.
[SPEAKER_00]: I can only do it 20 feet.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's awful.
[SPEAKER_01]: You meant 20 feet per turn.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right.
[SPEAKER_01]: And as long as the person is in range, you can keep going.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you can levitate yourself as high as you want to.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, what is the range of the spell?
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, I guess I can look it up on my phone.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, I'll look at it really fast, but I wanted to see Disguise Kit.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's like a new Mata, dude.
[SPEAKER_01]: You should get like a jacket.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I can live a T-shirt.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I can live a T. Teen wizard and I can live a T. You should buy a custom shirt and put that on just for this.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, there's a Christmas idea.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I can live a T.
[SPEAKER_01]: Maybe I'll do it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, the range is 60 feet.
[SPEAKER_01]: One creature or loose object of your choice that you can see within range rises vertically.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I can do it 20 feet per?
[SPEAKER_01]: Up 20 feet and remains suspended there for the duration, so it's 20 feet.
[SPEAKER_01]: The spell can levitate, a target that weighs 500 pounds, and a willing, unwilling creature that succeeds on a constitution saving throw.
[SPEAKER_01]: The target can move only by pushing or pulling against a surface, which allows it to move as if it were climbing.
[SPEAKER_01]: You can change the target's altitude by 20 feet in the other direction on your turn.
[SPEAKER_01]: By up to 20 feet in the other direction.
[SPEAKER_01]: The altitude up.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: If you are the target, you can move up or down as part of your move.
[SPEAKER_01]: Otherwise, you can use your action to move the target, which must remain in the spell's range.
[SPEAKER_01]: When the spell ends, the target floats gently to the ground.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's still a law.
[SPEAKER_01]: So basically, you can just move 20 feet up per turn.
[SPEAKER_01]: Or move somebody else.
[SPEAKER_00]: Up to 60 feet.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Up to 60 feet max, 20 feet per turn.
[SPEAKER_00]: So roughly three turns, two and a half, three turns total to get somebody up and then they can drop down or attach ropes or whatever.
[SPEAKER_00]: Exactly.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: But I mean, somebody could be climbing.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: It could be levitating.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, that's true.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: But I'm hoping to take them by stuff.
[SPEAKER_00]: I guess I could...
[SPEAKER_00]: It depends.
[SPEAKER_00]: It depends on if I can get my fourth level.
[SPEAKER_00]: I can Phantasmal Killer or Guard.
[SPEAKER_00]: Probably pretty fucking easy.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's a spell.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's a good spell.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's a levitation spell.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's gotta be done on a big guy.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I know.
[SPEAKER_01]: Could you levitate someone and just drop him?
[SPEAKER_00]: No, because once I cancel it, they slowly cancel it.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's lame.
[SPEAKER_00]: I was all like, ooh, can I take somebody out over a cliff?
[SPEAKER_01]: There is a spell that you could drop somebody.
[SPEAKER_01]: Could you, in theory, let's say you're hanging over a big chasm?
[SPEAKER_01]: It's called reverse gravity.
[SPEAKER_01]: Everything within a hundred foot radius of you, gravity reduces everything floats up.
[SPEAKER_01]: Up to 120 feet, and then you could just end it.
[SPEAKER_00]: And it's a six-sided damage for every 10 feet?
[SPEAKER_00]: It's actually more than that.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's more geometric.
[SPEAKER_01]: Let's say if you were levitating someone, but they fall slowly.
[SPEAKER_01]: And let's say you're hanging off by the side of a canyon, and you've got a big ogre or whatever.
[SPEAKER_01]: What if you just levitated them, moved them over the canyon, and then let him slowly fall?
[SPEAKER_00]: You can't move them over the canyon.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, what?
[SPEAKER_01]: No.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's a different spell.
[SPEAKER_00]: Is it just vertical?
[SPEAKER_01]: Altitude.
[SPEAKER_01]: They can go like this.
[SPEAKER_01]: If they have something, they can grab onto.
[SPEAKER_01]: But there is another spell called telekinesis, which is one where you can move them around.
[SPEAKER_01]: You can even do things like throw them against the wall and then just let it slowly flow.